[Musique]
voulant visiblement faire de l'humour
une internaute a eu la mauvaise idée de
faire un blackface autrement dit se
peindre le visage en noir pour imiter la
chanteuse qui n'a pas du tout apprécié
cet hommage cette personne est déguisé
en moi d'après al fin décembre c'est
l'humoriste donel jack'sman qui avait
été victime de racisme lors d'une
représentation de son spectacle donné
immédiatement répondu à ce spectateur
plus récemment c'est miss algérie qui a
fait les frais d'un déferlement de
racisme sur les réseaux sociaux après
son élection
khadija benhamou et noir de peau et ça
n'est pas du tout passé pour certains
algériens qui considèrent qu'elle ne
peut pas représenter l'algérie car selon
eux elle n'a pas la bonne couleur des
comportements insupportables qui semble
malheureusement s'intensifier de plus en
plus alors qu'est ce que vous pensez que
ça d'ailleurs je fais un gros bisous à
toi et l'espagne beaucoup et qui va
rejouer à nice et cannes il reviendrait
jouer à nice le 27 janvier est le
premier à la cigale tous les bénéfices
seront reversés à des associations qui
luttent contre le racisme et les disques
des discriminations merci d'onet
gingembre associé lia nakamura qui a été
touché après cette jeune fille est là la
1000 milles personnes qui a suivi
d'environ mille personnes par an oui oui
c'est 1000 de trop et franchement enfin
voila je pense qu'on est tous touchés
par ce sujet moi je suis maman d'un
métis mais ça veut rien dire je pense
que qu'on soit blanc ou on s'en fout
mais c'est des trucs
enfin on se rend compte que le racisme
en france l'on joué vivaces et
franchement c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment troublant on en a parlé ici on
en a parlé sur le sujet du football on
se rend compte que dans certains dans
certaines sphères de la société il n'ya
pas de gens de couleur
et ça on est en france on est en 2019 et
moi ça me fait chier
et quand je vois des trucs comme ça
franchement ça me fait gerber vous
voulez réagir là-dessus isabelle sur
l'âme je suis d'accord à part ça sauf
que le reste avec dsk n'a dit oui elle
sera par ailleurs vous savez que j'ai
l'air comme ça mais j'écoute toujours
fait les relances tu as vraiment j'ai
surtout qu'on était rentrés chez eux
écoutez je suis entièrement d'accord
avec ce que tu dis sauf que le racisme
c'est quelque chose de beaucoup plus
complexe et beaucoup plus compliqué que
ce qu'on dit moi par exemple j'ai fait
mes études dans une école de journalisme
il ya des 65 62 fils de chefs d'état
africains à saint germain du tout
décliné il y avait il y avait une haine
par exemple entre les les candidats les
jeunes des jeunes garçons journaliste
d'origine africaine et les les candidats
d'origine asiatique absolument ils ont
passé l'année entière à se battre entre
eux et les jeunes garçons asiatiques on
vous connaît belle balade dans le jeu
non ça veut dire c'est extrêmement
compliqué comme comme sujet et donnent
elles donnent elles c'est absolument
épouvantable merci merci serait juste
ravir une seconde sur le blackface oui
parce que le blackface j'ai pris une
citation du défenseur des droits
en france en mars 2017 se grimer en noir
renvoie à une vision péjorative et
humiliante des noirs donc c'est très
grave le blague mais quand certains je
sais peuvent le faire rissman l'avait
fait chier
oui mais c'est parce que c'est un
hommage aux arts l'ami météorites à
jouer avec ça parce que ça renvoie des
choses pas soit n'allait pas du tout à
vous lire en toi n'y aucun problème avec
lui mais sauf qu'il avait été taxé de
raciste ou lavilledieu supprimer ça
voilà un épisode malheureux mais pour
dollar lui c'est un hommage bien venu
faire et voilà ça a pas été faisable et
leurs épaules quand même série le stress
et ça et alors qu'un accord avec bien
sûr c'est chaouchi